meist kritisiere ich ja hier Politiker
aber heute möchte ich gerne ein loben
und das ist Armin Laschet hören wir doch
mal rein warum
und Nebenwirkungen völlig zu bestreiten
das war jedenfalls nie die Position der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz aber man
hat es nicht gesagt man hat es nicht
kommuniziert und das hat gerade Leugnung
Verschwörungstheoretikern Raum gegeben
weil jeder weiß dass es bei jeder
Impfung auch Nebenwirkungen geben kann
deshalb die Kritik am
Kommunikationsmanagement die ist
berechtigt und Sie haben gerade eben in
ihrem Beitrag wieder ein Beispiel
gesehen Herr Lauterbach verweist auf das
paul Ehrlich Institut
bei den Zahlen die gemessen werden mit
Impfschäden und das paul Ehrlich
Institut sagt wir müssen es gar nicht
das ist alles nichts was Vertrauen
schafft und ich glaube daraus müssen wir
lernen
hat ja recht mit Dinge zu benennen das
ist wichtig das ist wichtig von der
Politik und er spricht die Zahl von dem
paul Ehrlich Institut an das ist gar
nicht bemisst das kommen mir ein
bisschen vor wie ehrlich gesagt ihre
Recherchen während der corona-pandemie
wie schlimm ist das zahlende saß er denn
in unserem Land ja das Teil Desaster ist
tatsächlich sehr sehr groß vieles
basiert auf Annahmen auf auf Ideologie
auch auf der Verteidigung von von
narrativen die irgendwann gesetzt worden
von Politik und auch von Medien und es
ist wirklich sehr sehr schwer bei dieser
Thematik überhaupt verlässliche Aussagen
zu machen weil es hat z.B der Bericht
der
Evaluierungskommission der
corona-maßnahmen im vergangenen Sommer
gezeigt es hat sich eigentlich im Land
niemand wirklich darum gekümmert eine
verlässliche Datenlage zu schaffen das
heißt das was wir am Ende diskutieren
bei dieser Thematik
befindet sich dann immer etwas im
ungenauen und das ist eigentlich das ist
recht unwürdig für dieses Land wenn ich
ehrlich bin wir während der
corona-pandemie ganz viele Zahlen
schnell aufgedeckt oder haben einfache
Anfragen gestellt wo plötzlich klar war
man weiß es nicht was war denn für sie
die schockierendste Recherche wo sie
heute sagen das hat mich wirklich
geschockt also ehrlich gesagt ich bin so
richtig richtig tief eingestiegen Ende
2021 als wir
recherchiert haben die Zahlen zu der zu
den Geimpften und ungeimpften Inzidenzen
weiß nicht ob man sich noch daran
erinnert hier in der Runde damals hat
man ja gesagt die Inzidenz sehr
ungeimpft ist so und die Inzidenz der
geimpfen ist so und das war aber dann
wirklich ziemlich krass da da waren dann
immer die Erklärung dafür warum man sich
auf jeden Fall impfen lassen muss Weine
die Install das war auch zwei geht das
war eine Rechtfertigung auch für zwei
gay sondern haben wir dann irgendwie den
Tipp bekommen noch mal genauer
nachzufragen wieder in die eigentlich
diese Statistiken zusammen zustande
kommt und dann kam halt draußen das war
als erstes damals Bayern 70%
derer oder 70% der der der der neuen
Infektion der wusste man gar nicht ob
die Leute geimpft sind oder nicht
einfach dann den umgeimpften zugeteilt
wie man darauf kommt ist mir ehrlich
gesagt bis heute ein Rätsel und das
gleiche ist in Hamburg passiert das
gleiche auch in anderen Bundesländern
noch passiert und damals haben wir
darüber berichtet und das war für mich
eigentlich so der Einstieg der kommt wir
müssen eigentlich wirklich alles auf den
Kopf stellen weil wie kann das denn
bitte sein und irgendwie dann weitere
Motivation so ein bisschen war damals im
Landtag in in Bayern hat die FDP in der
Aktuelle Stunde wegen dieser
Berichterstattung einberufen und gesagt
Liebe Landesregierung hier die Zahlen
die die sind doch falsch also da sind
die Belege und das wurde dann geframt
als AFD spricht das hätte doch schon
irgendein rechtsextremer gesagt Moment
Vorsicht und quer dann kann das auch
schon erzählt oder jetzt toppitiert ihr
hier die Impfkampagne und ich stand da
da mit meinem Unterlagen sozusagen hat
gesagt aber Moment die Zahlen sind halt
gefällt sie AFD ich war AFD die FDP war
AFD ich war Querdenker ich war das
wirklich das war wirklich
heute gucke ich da drauf zurück sagt es
kann auch wirklich nicht wahr sein und
ich glaube auch viele derer die damals
gesagt haben dass doch querdenkerei und
was weiß ich diese werden auch heute
sagen da haben wir da lagen wir echt
falsch also aber das was sie ansprechend
hat auch Armin Laschet übrigens gesagt
in den Beitrag wir haben jetzt nun
Ausschnitt gesehen da hat er gesagt wer
nicht dafür war war Corona Leugner Frau
Speaker würden sie mitgehen in
Deutschland in der Medienlandschaft
wer da nicht mitmacht ist unser Corona
Leugner also ich glaube es ist wichtig
die Zahlen zu kennen so dass die
Menschen wissen woran Sie sind und ich
glaube es ist auch wichtig jetzt auch
was ist das 2 Jahre nachdem die
Impfungen begonnen wurden das auch zu
klären einfach alleine wegen des Gefühls
dass man weiß okay da wurde darauf
geachtet und da wurde nicht geschwindet
oder sonst was sondern wir wissen was da
passiert ist wir lernen auch daraus für
künftige vielleicht kommen da auch
weitere Pandemien auf uns zu wer weiß
und man muss daraus lernen so dass man
es in Zukunft besser machen kann es hat
ja mit Armin Laschet jetzt hier auch
nicht irgendwer
zugegeben kann man ja fast schon sagen
dass eigentlich keine Datenlage da wir
brauchen eine Kommission er war der
cdu-parteivorsitzende ist das vielleicht
auch ein Schuld Eingeständnis von der
CDU
ich glaube das vieles die Schuld
eingestehen müssen und die CDU natürlich
davon weg war auch mit SPD mit Karl
Lauterbach jetzt zusammen
ich würde mal sagen wir müssen es ein
bisschen berücksichtigen über welche
Zeit wir in der corona-pandemie sprechen
ich glaube anfangen als es ausgebrochen
ist März 2020 als es bewusst wurde ich
weiß es noch ich war in Paris Charlie
cool dass sie bei dieser riesen
Flughafen komplett gesperrt man wusste
es nicht die ersten Monate würde ich
immer noch als Lernkurve sehen aber
spätestens 21 ja
wenn man es nicht wusste und das sagen
wir alle das sagt auch ich man wusste es
nicht wie konnte denn dann die Politik
so arrogant sein aber zu entscheiden
ohne richtige zahlen ohne richtige
Fakten ohne richtige Daten wenn man
nichts wusste das ist ja fast man macht
die Augen zu und entscheidet was obwohl
man gar nicht weiß ja ich glaube 2020
war die Situation schon dass man einfach
mal ein Schutz der Bevölkerung rufen
musste wir mussten die Krankenhauses
sortieren ich glaube das waren ganz
wichtiger und verantwortungsvoller Punkt
da würde ich auch niemanden Schuld geben
aber er grün hat es ja so schön
aufgearbeitet ab 20 25 muss ich ja dann
wirklich mal Fragen auf welcher
Grundlage habe ich zum Beispiel
Einschränkungen vorgenommen auf welcher
Grundlage durfte ich denn mit meinem
Hund alleine nicht mehr rausgehen um den
Grunewaldsee und ihnen ausführen hier in
Berlin durfte ich es aber in
Baden-Württemberg zum Beispiel nicht und
das sind Sachen die müssen wir jetzt
aufarbeiten weil die haben ganz viel mit
Glaubwürdigkeit in unsere System und in
unseren Rechtsstaat zu tun aber Hans die
Glaubwürdigkeit ist ja immer noch
angegriffen wenn man sieht Karl
Lauterbach stellt sich wieder ins
Interview und dann sagt Armin Laschet
naja aber das gibt das voll ehrlich
Institut gar nicht hier da ist ja dann
schon die Frage hat es eigentlich nie
aufgehört wir zahlen oder
Etikettenschwindel politik ist die Kunst
des Möglichen wenn es so viele zeigen
gibt und so viel Verwirrung dann kann
auch was passieren nicht die wird nicht
in Schuldigen aber eines muss man schon
sagen da bin ich gerade bei ihnen weil
am Anfang war man verrückt aber Vorsicht
ist die Mutter der Porzellankiste
langsam konnte man gelernt haben was
wirklich jetzt zahlen sind wenn ich
denke die elendslangen Streit zum wir an
oder durch Corona oder mit gestorben ist
ja alles diese diese sprachverwirrungen
auch aber nur zurückschauen
die Datenlage war nicht da ist es wurde
auch mit falschen Zahlen sogar hantiert
ja also dann schauen wir warum das so
war aber ich würde ein bisschen
vorausschauen und ich würde sagen was
machen die jetzt weiter weil das was ich
jetzt sehe alles oft wunderbar es ist
alles in Ordnung und jetzt geben alle
ohne Masken und so alles wieder normal
wir haben gerade jetzt wieder eine
behinderte neue Epidemie eine neue Welle
die gerade wieder anfängt ja in anderen
Ländern z.B einen Heimatland in
Österreich wird gemessen dass wir
wahrscheinlich bereits zwischen 10 und
12 % Erkrankungen haben ja im Lande
aufgrund der abwasserwerte und so weiter
also mir ist wichtiger was machen wir
jetzt
harmloser nicht harmloser die Spitäler
werden schon langsam trotzdem wieder
voll be alte Leute bei denen ist weniger
harmlos deswegen wird mehr wie mehr
interessieren die Diskussion was machen
wir jetzt wie gehen wir in Zukunft damit
um und daraus aus dem was passiert ist
die richtigen Schlüsse zu tun für die
Schlüssel vielleicht noch einen Punkt
wirklich wichtig ist ich glaube dass
sowohl auf der einen Seite der
corona-leugner und schwurbler die gab es
ja auch die Faktor also die gab es ja
wirklich
oder ich meine jetzt schon so eher Leute
die dann irgendwas von BRD GmbH sprechen
also das war ja auch eine Mischung die
da hoch kam aber auf den gleichen Seite
hatten wir natürlich auch sozusagen
diese übersichtigen also ich erinnere
mich noch wir haben im Herbst letzten
Jahres noch darüber gesprochen ob wir
wieder eine maskenpflicht im Land Berlin
einführen ja oder nein also wir hatten
schon auch Menschen die sozusagen sich
in dieser Angst Vorstellung in dieser
Wahnvorstellung des totalen Schutzes sie
so eingenistet haben dass ich glaube und
da kommen wir zu der Verantwortung der
Medien natürlich dann auch wirklich
sauber recherchieren zu müssen weil
natürlich jeder sich das rausgreift was
seine gefühlte Wahrheit irgendwie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
nehmen unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
wild kämpft für Sie